[Musique]
[Rires]
allô c'est le regard que vous voulez
elle va tant mieux tony tonique poli
tonique d'ovni tomino tonton pas touche
pipi topo de la journée avec mon ami
marc on vous a préparé une série
d'épreuves physiques la refais la nature
j'ai à faire je n'attends rien de la
bouffe dans les yeux alors bien sûr
alors avec mon ami marc parce que
parfois c'est bien surprise aux [ __ ]
de ta mère je vois doit être content
qu'on soit d'accord c'est pas moi qui ai
dit tu es bon je sais pas moi qui tu es
j'ai l'impression qu'à comme une
rancoeur quelque chose de délétère avec
beaucoup de rancoeur envers marc oui et
c'est normal
et cette ambiance on vous a concocté une
série d'épreuves physiques et sportives
afin de voir la quille
surprise on fait peur sur [ __ ] mais
c'était parfait presse
voilà maintenant nature watts est bon on
est record sur cette choquer tout cas
ces épisodes du show qui il est tombé
malade parce qu'il a mangé du parti fils
est en fait c'était un peu des pieds
mais câline est aussi on se rend compte
que djoko
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu es mort depuis tardel merde je crus
et avec mon ami marc on vous avait
solennellement que vous aimez vous
rigolez la arrête de galeries on y va
c'est parti observez-vous alors non
arrêter un nouvel exercice
on va non c'est pas ça l'exercice
docteur match non renouer la confiance
avec marc parce qu'il le faut et renouer
la confiance quand j'étais jeune en fait
ça va vous faire du bien
qu'exercer maggio c'est pas possible ça
va vous faire du bien
oh je suis touché n'en parle ça c'est
bonjour faisant ça je peux parler deux
secondes pdm et des pipots tutu ou le
train jérôme le savons mais
malheureusement j'ai appris très tard
que ça n'était que des jouets pipeau
tout chaud le train a normalement jamais
paulo pipeau tutu j'écoule pipeau tchou
tchou le train jérôme la flûte mais on a
du souffle pour quelqu'un qui fume
tu peux l'appeler maman si tu veux ça la
dérange pas tu peux l'appeler maman si
tu veux cela dérange pas du tout ça
m'aide
baba fiston marc montpetit marocain mais
moi aussi je me fais appeler ses vrais
l'anus valérie je plaisante pas
mais tu plaisantes non je plaisante pas
plaisante pas mais je dois te laisser
j'ai autre chose à faire et j'aurai
raccroché sans craindre les choix de
corneille
c'est terrible c'est des choix qui
seront durs
il
[Musique]
goûtez moi ça l'a d'ailleurs est
toujours devant n'a pas pu la sortir mes
marques
qu'est ce qui se passait exactement j'ai
couché ensemble
elle est drôle
moi j'ai un peu débarbouiller mais vous
avez couché ensemble ou pas et à la
framboise en effet vous savez la presse
[Musique]
mark est bien meilleur que celui-là sans
pour sa salle août
il envoie ou là je suis parti nouveau
bon ça a vu juste omis dans la cuvette
des toilettes
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est autre chose que ta lettre je vois
la malaxe à ce choix s'est fait mal
toi aussi tu me fais mal on va faire la
pêche ensemble pour éclater les arômes
ça éclate la gueule
[Musique]
ça t'a plu
soit vraiment que je couche